un peu de patinage sur le soleil pour
commencer l'année 2021 au mont royal
aujourd'hui des amis de la lumière de la
compagnie un peu de chaleur c'est ce que
plusieurs sont venus chercher dans le
vieux port de montréal dans la nuit du
31 décembre
quand savais qu'il y avait une ambiance
ici avec les lumières avec la musique
c'est le fin tout le monde est content
et ça fait du bien de sortir de la
maison
on est fatigué de confinement c'est
vraiment on en a marre c'est nouvel an
dont on a fêté ça à québec les policiers
sont intervenus dans trois
rassemblements dans le secteur de la
colline parlementaire
des rassemblements interdits selon les
autorités qui ont remis 46 constats
d'infraction pour non respect des règles
sanitaires
les corps policiers de montréal et de
ses banlieues feront leur bilan au cours
des prochains jours
mais pour l'instant rien de majeur à
signaler en était seul mais en à zoom
avec nos plans et notre famille c'est
différent mais c'est ça si l'année 2020
est synonyme de confinement pour
plusieurs coupures d'ailleurs avec les
attentes sont presque toutes les mêmes
pour 2021
ça peut pas être pire que c'était donc
on espère que les choses vont
s'améliorer rapidement la santé puis de
pouvoir voir nos amis et nos familles le
plus rapidement par ses membres et que
le confinement ils finissent le plus
vite possible bien que le cabinet
fouchet l'espoir d'une nouvelle année
qui voit tranquillement la cause il
disparaît
ici elle car on radio canada montréal
non